(SIRENS WAIL)
REPORTER: As case numbers
spike around the world,
the race to find
a COVID-19 vaccine
is gaining pace.
The pandemic is burning
out of control.
SPEAKER:
I'll turn now to the director
of the FDA's vaccine division.
VACCINE DIVISION DIRECTOR:
My wife, she's teaching
an art class upstairs,
so hopefully we won't
hear a lot. (CHUCKLES)
♪ (MELLOW MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Our process must increase trust
in vaccines.
Without that,
we're gonna continue to work
in places like my basement.
SPEAKER 2: We've never
created a new vaccine
in less than five years.
We're going to defeat this
with vaccine strategies
that have never
been used before.
SPEAKER 3: We do have
to face the possibility
that it could be never.
We all have the same goal:
Get a safe and effective
vaccine.
DONALD TRUMP: It's called
Operation Warp Speed.
ANTHONY FAUCI:
I'm walking a fine line,
being the only one
in that task force
who's not afraid
to tell the West Wing
what they don't want to hear.
There is something
that's called reality.
SPEAKER 4: One shot
and we're getting antibody
responses.
This vaccine
might actually work.
-(VIDEO CALL ALERT)
-SPEAKER 5: Hello, everybody.
SPEAKER 6: Good news.
We made it.
(CHEERING)
♪ (FRENZIED MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER 7: Ninety-four percent
efficacy for the vaccine.
This is insane!
It's a revelation of science.
REPORTER 2: Overnight,
a potential turning point.
SPEAKER 8: Getting this
vaccine out is gonna be
one of the biggest tasks
we've ever undertaken.
SPEAKER 9: New variants
will emerge in areas
of the world
where vaccine coverage
is much lower.
SPEAKER 10: This is all
part of our reality now.
If all you care about
is yourself,
if you wanna go back
to commerce, tourism,
you will not be able to do that
if the epidemic's raging
in other countries.
SPEAKER 11:
Their perspective is, "Look,
we want to help the world,
but we need to protect
our people first."
DR. TEDROS ADHANOM GHEBREYESUS:
We're asking all countries
to be part of a global effort
to ensure some people
are vaccinated in all countries,
not all people
in some countries.
SPEAKER 12: This is
a catastrophic moral failure.
GHEBREYESUS:
We're in the race of our lives.
Just give us the vaccines.
♪ (MUSIC CLIMAXES) ♪
What happens next
is up to us.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES)